we all
ready good good morning everybody
Welcome to Transportation before we get
started if I can ask representative veu
pledge
thank you for that okay I'm G to open up
our first public hearing House Bill
1329 relative to creating special number
plates for fire departments and the
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
welcome good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee
this will be the easy one of the two
bills I have today in here so I was
approached by the chief of the exitor
fire department and he thought it would
be a a good thing to have the license
plates like the Cruisers have you know
they have MP and there's a designation
that tells you what town they're from
and what number Cruiser it is and he was
looking to do something very similar to
that for the fire service uh plate that
stands out that it's a fire department
vehicle and you know and we'll come up
with the code probably following what
the police use for the town designations
seeing how they already have them and U
thing and that's about all I have I'll
take
questions uh yeah any questions from the
committee rep representative rich
a volunteer dep does that make any
differ no it's for all okay all of the
fire department Vehicles not like the
individual
members any other questions yeah I do uh
can you refresh my memory what do they
have for plates now for the municial
vehicles for for the fire department
yeah just the G plates the government
plates okay but the police have their so
they have on a blue stripe that comes
down the side says MP Municipal Police
and then in blue letters their town code
and the cruiser code or vehicle code yep
representative Hill I'm sorry what what
would be the benefit of that but so I
know like some of the chief's cars
aren't don't have the big light bars on
them anymore so they're looking so that
they can be identified as a fire vehicle
as they approach a scene um
and it just lets people know that it is
a fire department vehicle
not like
our I work in E
eping and our fire inspector has a
retired police car that we tried to
dress up as much as we can as a fire car
and because my selectman won't let us
put a nice big fire patch on it we have
to put the town seal so police and that
car still look quite a lot alike and she
gets accused of being a police officer
all the time and she really hates that
so if you had the red plate on there
they would know that it's the fire
department not the police department y
follow up thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for taking my question um does
it are you
limited why why would it matter I guess
um is there are there circumstan
where having the government plate on it
um gets you stopped going to a scene
instead of it could be you
know I've been pulled
over um then again not in my vehicle but
I have lights that weren't on I was
headed to a call but didn't think I
really need needed to put my lights on
on the highway because sometimes that
just causes people confusion and such so
he was just cruising along and got
stopped but they did let me go when they
told him I was going to a call another
followup followup please um but that's
on your personal vehicle I agree what
I'm trying to dra the distinction so I'm
going to tell you my Chief's car right
now you wouldn't know it's a fire car
right so he could be scooting down the
road and if he didn't have all his red
lights on you would get stopped but it
has a government plate yes okay thank
you and why is he scooting down the road
without his lights on well sometimes if
you're like the third went in on the
call and you're just going there to
supervise like I said sometimes it's
better to be stealthy
because people do crazy things when they
see lights in the rear view mirror like
stomp on the brakes in the middle of the
road so fair enough I was just having a
little fun we're just trying to We're
just trying to loosen up for a a long
day here this wasn't my idea
this was the
chief and I don't see him so fair enough
uh any other
questions representer Fox thank you Mr
chairman um so just so it's clear these
are for fire department owned vehicles
and not personal vehicles that are used
for Fire Department business correct
thank
you apparently the exitor fire chief
just wants to be a cop in Disguise so he
wants his own little plates that what I
can tell you representative Jones Thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
presenting this um so I heard you say
red so these these wouldn't be the
traditional license plate colors of New
Hampshire these would be R so on the
police one there's a stripe that comes
down the the Leading Edge right that and
in it is MP Municipal Police in white
letters so so I'm assuming we would do
the red stripe down and it would
have you know uh
FM right and then the letters would be
readed on the white background oh okay
good answer thank
you okay representative gisy thank you
Mr chairman and thank you represented
for taking my question just for me to
get clarity would a fire can a
firefighter get these plates for their
vehicle no thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very
much and for everybody I don't have a
card from the New Hampshire uh
Department of Safety War mode Vehicles
so apparently they don't have a position
and it is a relatively small fiscal note
uh chair recogniz is next up
representative
McGuff did I pronounce that
right that's okay I think only the clerk
gets it right uh it's representative M
I'll never it'll never happen again
thank you Mr chairman nice to see all
the members of the transportation
committee for the first time in about
23 years oddly enough the last time I
was here and this is this was the
beginning of my testimony on the next
bill oddly the last time I was here was
also for a special plate bill and I know
how you love them because chairman
Packard our current Speaker also loved
them 22 years ago and you may detect a
little sarcasm in my voice um I did not
know I didn't happen to notice that
representative PR's bill I think we were
elected together as freshmen actually uh
I didn't happen to notice that his bill
was on the calendar just before mine but
I wanted to take less than two minutes
to tell you why I think it's a good idea
and why I think you should consider and
and I believe this has come up before
even after I introduced it 20 years ago
I think you should consider um AAL
special plate in addition an actual
special plate like many states do with a
mtis cross or Star of Life or EMS or
fire responders especially the volunteer
towns um I was a volunteer for many many
years I'm still licensed paramedic in
three states 33 years now uh and my
eight or so years on marac ambulance
rescue service that was a constant issue
um you know getting plates back or you
know just having the Little Rocker plate
that we've all seen before that usually
goes above
um a a a plate that has the proper
symbol multis Cross or Star of Life is
what's commonly done in many other
states you've probably seen them in New
York and Pennsylvania 80% of EMS is
provided EMS and fire in the state or of
EMS fire Personnel in the country are
volunteers of course the other 20% do
80% of the calls so in you know fair
fair disclosure so anyway that's my only
input on this um I do think it's it's a
good idea whatever we can do to
distinguish it especially these days
when you roll up on the scene when you
when you onsite something and people
wonder who the heck are you and you have
to say well I'm a paramedic and maybe
they believe you maybe they don't you
don't necessarily want to pull your
license out but if you're driving a car
that has a multis cross on it uh or a
starve life on it they're much more
likely to accept your assistance
roadside for those of us that still uh
stop and don't practice the EMS salute
and Drive
by so so I'd encourage you to consider
that that's all thank you very much
questions on the practicality of that or
anything questions from the
committee representative sellers yeah
thank you Mr chair so just to be clear I
just want to make sure so
these I'm maybe I'm hearing double
that's why I'm ask these would be on my
personal vehicle with the symbol on
there that would indicate so people know
that you're driving up would have uh
that you're an EMS or fire correct
during your either off duty response or
on duty volunteer response I mean at it
at Mar m amulance rescue service when
that organization still existed to
augment the the full-time fire which it
doesn't any longer uh but we had teams
each night of four or five uh volunteer
responders that would respond from their
home in their personal vehicles
representative dry marget dry is is one
of those folks um or Virginia dry um
that has done it for many many years she
could actually speak to it if she
happened to be here but um there's a lot
of volunteer EMS and a lot of volunteer
fire in the state many times you're
responding directly to the scene in your
personal vehicle sometimes you're
responding to the ambulance garage or
fire fire station to pick up a vehicle
but in any case it makes it considerably
more easy to identify uh in my opinion I
know we've had this bill a couple of
times and we have a lot of special
plates but times have changed in terms
of people you know believing when you
present yourself as a as a professional
license provider you know are you aren't
you if you have a plate I think gets a
so representative Fox thank you Mr
chairman I I just asked that question of
Representative PR and he answered
totally differently he said they would
not be used for on personal vehicles
they would be used only for vehicles
owned by the fire department indeed
thank you for bringing up and I should
have been made it more clear I'm
suggesting an addition to this bill or
an amendment to use this bill as a
vehicle to do that also to accomplish
what we of proof suggesting and
something else in that's Germain uh to
it so I am suggesting Amendment I'm
happy to prepare it I'm I'm sure I have
it drafted from prior thank
you well it does save my question
because I was trying to see where it
would apply to volunteer and I don't see
that here either yeah okay uh any other
questions from the committee seeing none
much and with no other people signed up
to speak on House Bill 1329 I'll close
the public
hearing uh next up at
10:20 which is in three minutes uh House
Bill
okay welcome back I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill
1354 relative to special number plates
for surviving spouses of
veterans um chair recognizes the prime
sponsor of Representative Sellers and I
see somebody else is that representative
CBO yes sir okay two out of the way
welcome good morning uh Mr chair and
transportation committee I appreciate
the time here and this is a uh a bill
that I sponsored and Prime sponsored as
a a veterans bill because of a
constituent has heard or run into a
problem where the spouse would pass away
and this bill would say within a year or
just after a year the um the surviving
spouse would have to give up the
veterans plate that they might have had
for a long time and so this person
wanted to actually say you know this
should be until maybe the spouse gets
remarried or
indefinitely if they don't remarry
because it's very personal to them and
that's why they would like to keep the
plates at this point so that that's the
main gist of this and he on the sheet I
provided you is just informational on
different areas and and uh part of the
law there that you know it is affected
by this
so not sure what more I can say on it
and but I'm willing for questions and
the other representative here do you
want to say something now I would see if
they have any questions for sure let's
do questions thank
you all right uh to make it official
though if you are at the table if I can
just get you to state your name excuse
me if I can just get you to state your
name representative cro my name is
representative Karen cabro Hillsboro
District 45 Greenville Mason brookln and
Hollis thank you very much just to keep
it official for our YouTube Watchers any
questions from the committee
representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair um good morning
I have a question and you'll have to
forgive my lack of
knowledge but other than signifying that
the person in the car or may be a
veteran or is a veteran do you get any
are there any special privileges that
come with having a veteran's license
plate on a car in a state of New
Hampshire whether it's parking or tolls
or
anything so I personally have a veterans
license plate except for right now but
uh it's still in the back of my tra my
truck in the back seat not not that I'm
aware I mean it's just a a status that I
was a veteran or a veteran of a
particular service but I don't get
special parking or free parking or free
tolls or anything else like that they
working on that quick followup yep
so I guess
again nothing zero just a strictly like
you said a status or just letting people
know not anything that that's my
understanding and I've been using my
plate for years and I've gotten nothing
except the status to let other people
know that I'm a veteran that's it thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question question um I guess it's a
two-part question one there's no um
current charge as I recall for having a
correct I I can't remember I it's not
free it's not free it's it may be the
same cost as a regular plate but I I
don't believe it's
free um okay well I think we can get
that answer as we come along but the
other part of this is do you know of any
reason
um anything magical about that one year
that you're able to take the plate is
there a uh is there a
um if that was changed to five years
would it make any any difference um
regarding the law um there's no there's
nothing magical about that one is that
what I understand from well the the
current law does say one right so they
and they want to make it indefinite I
like to make it indefinite
right uh if we made it five years I
don't know if there's any conflict any
place else I'm not aware of that uh and
and again all that might do is delay the
person the the surviving spouse um
needing or being forced to get another
plate um followup yeah follow up thank
you um but it's not for purposes of
identification of of who is is driving
the car or something like that there's
no there's no um
special designation that uh that that
person who was technically not a veteran
would be driving that car there's no um
there's nothing stopping someone driving
a car that has veteran plates even
though they weren't a veteran is that
right that is correct I even I other
household members in my house they use
my vehicle and my plates are on it so
there's nothing stopping just it's not
like a handicap placard right and
parking someplace and putting it up or
having a handicap plate it's uh it's not
like that at all it's literally no
different than a regular plate but it's
just an
identification thank you and that's true
of all of these in
this testimony correct yeah yeah better
yes thank
you um just for the committee's
knowledge we do have uh a member of the
state veterans advisory committee here
signed up to speak so if the questions
are more appropriate to that person like
the one I have uh you can hold off uh
any other questions for the sponsors go
ahead representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here and thank you for
your service um this seems like
a uh wear your hard on your sleeve type
of issue
uh and it kind helps the spouse keep the
Legacy going so I I like that part of it
I just some clarity on some of the
things you already answered
so a spouse can't apply for it after the
after the this decease of the first
spouse right it has to be a carryover
that's correct okay
and and the other part you mentioned was
if they
remarry they don't have the right to to
use that plate anymore they would have
time thank
you the other one thing I want to state
is I just happened to hear from a
constituent just yesterday he says
because they they came on the other side
of it and say well the veterans plate
there is for a veteran and someone else
that's has it on the vehicle that their
spous has passed away they were never a
veteran so they're saying you know is
this right to be able to have so looking
at both sides of the coin one was saying
yes I'm a veteran I have a right to have
that plate and the other side saying
well you never served why you have that
plate so speak I just want to bring that
up and just so everybody is on the same
page not try to hide I would speak to
this part
um my family's been in the military for
as long as I can remember my father
wasn't able to get into the army but my
grandfather was uncles I went to a
military honors at Fort SS in Oklahoma
this summer to watch my uncle be buried
and I watched my aunt very proudly St
there during those
honors um it gave me great pride to know
that I was co-sponsoring this
bill um because I know that that woman
Sat by him for 53 years doing the weekly
shopping at PT moving every two years
bringing those children basically as a
single
parent um and my grandfather who did it
they were married for 60 plus
years um they live in states that do
respect veterans I believe um in Texas
and
Arizona um I am the lone Democrat on
this bill and I am asking for you to
recognize the sacrifices that these
families are going through as mobile
crisis medical lead at Harbor Care
Health and um Wellness Clinic I saw a
lot of people there as a physician
assistant um I saw a lot of veterans who
did not not have really good resiliency
skills I watched their families Reach
Out desperately for me to help um as
their provider for medical assisted
treatment for substance use
disorder I know what their families are
going through even if you don't
recognize they may not be veterans but
they're just as invested in supporting
those veterans this is a very tiny
population of the country that are
willing to step up and do this even less
of them are willing to give their entire
careers this is a very small act for the
general court of New Hampshire to give
to these families yes it's just an honor
but it is a symbol thank you thank
you representative rbo thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question I
I'm curious about the remarriage Clause
was that sort of an effort to compromise
or find balance between folks saying
that you weren't a veteran yourself to
about okay because I I can see an
argument to not need that addition even
if someone did remarry you know to still
be able to keep the plate but I was
curious I I think that once you've made
a commitment to somebody else I think
that honor would probably in in
rightfully ethically I feel should fall
away okay um but I do want to add that
if there is any wording that's in this
bill that you find contested um I would
ask you to let us know what we can do to
fix it um and pass thank you thank you
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
uh next up chair recognizes
representative M who is in support of
the
bill good morning again wow three times
in 22 years two in a row on license
plate bills it's probably not a record
but um so I I am here as a co-sponsor
and in support of this bill and I've
submitted written testimony to the clerk
which I'm happy to email out as well or
or the clerk could um it's a pretty
simple Bill helps support and remember
and honor the enduring Legacy of the
deceased
veteran um constituents came to me
specifically constituents involved with
who work with surviving spouses and the
Military Officers Association and the
surviving spouses of those those
military veterans um a few of the
constituents are getting on in years and
it's on their mind the presence of that
veterans plate on their husband or
wife's vehicle it's a source of Pride
and a source of honor and it's something
they want to hang on to and right now
they can't after a certain period of
time they are likely to be presented
with that flag
gravide that'll go on the Manel and
that'll be pretty significant to them
but that everyday reminder uh on
probably on the vehicle that their
spouse may may have maintained to
military standards at least the the ones
that I've spoken
to um it's a real source of Pride and it
doesn't come with any real special
privileges everything else you need your
DD214 or military ID for you know to go
down to hansam and Shop or get into the
state parks or that sort of thing so
really the purpose of this bill is just
to recognize that unique and enduring
connection of surviving spouses it's
that simple few more details in my
written testimony but some of it some of
it's already been said so I'll keep it
short no thank you for that any question
questions from the committee seeing none
thank
you and the final speaker on House Bill
1354 Kevin Grady represented State
veterans advisory committee in support
see yes sir great to be back um for the
record my name is Kevin Grady uh I am a
25y year Air Force veteran and I a uh
25y year resident of the town of hookit
New Hampshire and today I'm here it's my
first first first trip to Transportation
this uh this cycle I'll be back for one
down the road as well that we're
following but I want to just give you an
idea of what we do uh because some of
you may be new to the committee the
state veterans advisory committee is is
uh chartered by state RSA 115 colon a-8
if you want to look it up uh and we're
we have 20 member organizations that are
that are sponsored by veteran support
organizations in the state these are
names that would be familiar with you to
you the American Legion the Veterans of
Foreign Wars all of the I represent the
air and space forces Association now um
so we have a legislative committee which
I chair that every year we scrub all of
the bills that are going to come before
the legislature and this this session
there's 20 of them uh that we feel have
better an impact and we take a position
on that and then I come and I tell you
what that position is and I I feel the
pain of our our previous uh
representative who spoke when he talked
talked about license plate bills I was
certainly here for the uh the transition
to from Li from a whole new license
plate to cost $64,000 to put in the
system to a sticker that you can put on
uh through that controversy and it's the
it's the running joke of our committee
some of you of a certain age may
remember the so kung kung fu with David
kerine at the beginning the old man says
when you can take the pebble from my
hand grasshopper it'll be time to leave
the standing joke is when I can get a
legislative session without a license
plate Bill it'll be time for somebody
else to be the share um this bill has
come up before and our veterans have
really been kind of hard over about the
position that you know the veteran plate
is for the veteran and this time I asked
them I said is it possible that our
position has mellowed on this and I also
told them that when I come and talk to
committees the thing that I want to
leave them with because I don't want
every time you see me I've got my hand
out looking for money I want to leave
you with the idea that that if one of us
serves the whole family serves okay so
it those people that are our family
members endure a lot of sacrifices so
that we can do what we do and keep you
safe and as we were discussing this bill
um we had a very impassioned plea from
one of our female members of the
committee that said you know the bottom
line here is that the military does so
little for surviving spouses that a
license plate is a really pretty small
price to pay to continue that Legacy and
and that really did win the day it
wasn't a unanimous decision it was like
14-6 but I'm here to tell you that that
we we do support this bill now we think
it does good things for visibility
whenever we see have visibility for
veterans it it helps us out to
representative Hills question it costs
$4 to get a veteran plate and every year
the person has to pay the standard uh
bills to the St State and property taxes
and all that stuff that go along with
registering that plate so the difference
in cash on this thing would be the
difference what would be the whatever
we're currently charging for a plates
maybe 12 bucks I don't know I'm not I'm
not the expert on exactly what that is
but if we made the surviving spouse
change to that then that's uh what we
would what we'd
have um I had a question I had an answer
to representative Rambo's question but I
can't remember it off the top of my head
the question that you asked ma'am I
believe it's about to oh did you have a
question I'm sorry are you are you all
set yes I'm subject to your questions
then I'll I'll I'll I'll stop now and
and entertain questions thank you sir
representative
bro thank you for taking my question the
Clause regarding the surviving uh
remarrying The Sur yes I think that
that's put in there because it's fairly
consistent with what the military does
in terms of surviving spouse for example
you you're your let's say my wife for
example I've been in I was in for 25
years we have healthc care through the
military through Tri care okay if if we
were to get divorced or I if I was to
die then she would um actually not
divorced but if I was to die she would
keep that health care until such time as
she remarried so there are a lot of the
the handful of benefits that a surviving
spouse keeps when when the the the
member dies
that that language is consistent with
with what you would find in the federal
statutes on that that's helpful thank
you any other questions seeing none I
feel much better I do remember uh I
thought I remembered that when this bill
first came out years the law that your
position was for the year so to see that
change makes all the difference for me
um in terms of your other statement too
looks like I'm probably going to be safe
here for a while too representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman and thank you take
my question um I had a veteran spouse
say to me the other day and I'm
wondering if I can get your comment on
her comment she said um when I lost my
husband every single tie um that I had
with with him has been severed except
for the plate at this point and I know
I've only got a year to have this plate
but that will be the last thing that I
have that that is a reminder of that
does that sound well I I I hope that the
whatever member organizations that and
and most of us veterans are members of
at least one or two veteran service
organizations I would hope that the
members of that group would reach out to
that surviving spouse and and and try
and provide that that continuity perhaps
the spouses of the people that are in
those organizations would reach out as
well I know we do in in a a veterans
organization I have called the dallion
that is a society of of military Pilots
that we we pay for ground and flight
instructions for kids during the summer
to learn how to solo an airplane you
know we reach out we've got six or seven
surviving spouses that are are still get
invitations to all of our meetings and
dinners and those kind of things I would
hope that that happens but what you're
describing is pretty much exactly to to
representative Rambo's question it's
pretty much exactly the way it is you
everything pretty much goes away once
that that military that veteran passes
away every everything that you used to
have kind of goes away thank
you right seeing no other questions
thank you very much thank you uh I have
nobody else signed up to speak on House
Bill 1354 so I'll close the public
hearing I give us a few minutes might be
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1416 FN relative
to prohibiting parking of non-electric
vehicles in spaces designated for
charging electric
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative funner good morning and
who is with you thank you very much this
is the other sponsored representative
Faxton from okay
Troy I can get your both to introduce
yourselves for the
record my name is taxton uh I represent
Troy and Fitz William chesher District
12 thank you much I'm Barry fauler Prime
sponsor representing Swansea and
Richmond which is chure
10 um here to introduce HB
1416 it's a bill that would create a
fine for parking in a space that's
reserved for electric vehicles while
charging uh it would be a $100
fine uh and it has an enforcement
mechanism that's similar to what we now
have for handicap spaces that is a uh an
owner of a of the
facility or the owner driver of a car of
electric car that needs to use the space
or wants to use the space uh can submit
an affidavit and photographic evidence
that there's a an improper vehicle
parked in a uh electric vehicle charging
space uh to the local law enforcement
Authority and they would issue the
ticket
um why why do we submit this uh bring is
a very significant public and private
investment in these charging facilities
the the level so-called level three
charging facilities can run tens of
thousands of dollars per
stall uh this paid through by a
combination of private and public
investment or public subsidies for these
and significant private investment and
if somebody is taking up a space and
uh that could otherwise be producing
Revenue it's really a
u a serious matter that U you know
affects the ability of people to to put
this Services out
there
um you know the availability of charging
public charging stations is one of the
major issues in
the facing the adoption of electric
vehicles uh Nationwide worldwide really
uh you can see the difference in sorry
terms of what the Tesla has done in
terms of providing spaces versus U you
know as a as a lead that this was one of
the first things that they did in order
to ensure that that they could
successfully enter and dominate this
Market um the problem with enforcement
is also a disincentive to owners I me uh
shopping mall owners uh hotels
restaurants
other uh venues that would might benefit
by attracting uh drivers that drivers of
electric vehicles if they could provide
the space I somebody's coming up from
New York wants to stay at a local
hotel you know they can get here on the
the range they they started with but
they need to plug in overnight in order
to get home so there are Travelers who
do seek out hotels that offer these
charging facilities and
if if the hotels or other venues can't
do anything about people parked
illegally then it's a disincentive to
provide that service and we lose
potential revenue from outstate
Travelers um just in terms of who uses
these things uh Nationwide 82% of all
electric vehicle charging is done at
home another 10% is done at work or
Fleet charging so we're talking about
something on the order of 8% of of
charging that's done in these public
stations either level two or level three
uh and you know these are people who are
you know not local residents be you know
because mostly in this state in
particular they people charge at home
but people driving in from
elsewhere who use these facilities and
rely on these facilities in order to
plan a trip and if they can't find a
place to charge then they go elsewhere
so I think it's a it's a public issue to
the to the
state um in terms of our ability to
attract tourists attract visitors
attract business uh
users uh and so it's not just a you know
a private theft of services problem it's
a it's a public problem as well so that
is the reason why I thought this bill
it good morning rep
Representatives as a long-term selectman
and School Board member whenever I have
had to somebody comes up with an idea
I've always said who does it help and
who does it
hurt so who does this bill hurt well
rude
people um that's who it hurts and uh it
who does it help and as a small business
owner it helps me and I'll tell you why
uh in the town where I live
which is on the route between the city
of Keane and the City of
Boston um I happen to own a laundromat
which has an excellent opportunity for a
Tesla charging station the franchise on
each Tesla charging station one post one
gas pump is
$55,000 that's before I hire the
electrician to install it and before I
buy the equipment so any small business
owner that makes that investment is
making a substantial
investment and to not be able to have
that space accessed by my potential
customers which there would be a
significant number of driving from
Boston to Keane or big numbers by
chesher County standards you know um
would be damaging to me as a small
business owner and really it goes back
to who did it benefit parking there
people who were being rude people who
were trying to make a statement against
electric vehicles I own a lot of cars I
own an electric car electric cars are
here to
stay um I can tell you that there are
anti-electric car activists if that is
in the city of keen behind uh the
Colonial Theater we had two charging
stations that were installed by the city
and that is one place where people would
park to make a statement and block
people from charging and there was uh
actually one someone took bolt cutters
and cut off the uh whatever you call it
the extension cord that you plug your
car into so it hurts those people who
are out going out of their way to make a
statement uh that you shouldn't be able
to drive an electric car I think this is
a very straightforward and very simple
bill and I I hope that we can have uh
Barry and I Barry is a Democrat I'm a
Republican and I hope that we can have a
pretty straightforward and bipartisan
positive decision on this coming out of
committee thank you thank you questions
from the committee I saw representative
Jones
first thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you representatives for being here um I
see this bill as you're staying with the
changing of times and you're being
proactive instead of reactive and I know
you want a question Mr chair so yes so
uh here it comes
um instead of this be is it better for
this to become an R Statewide RSA or to
have allow the municipalities to create
their own
ordinances my answer to that is it
really needs to be a Statewide lot uh
small towns would not have the ability
effectively to the town of Troy is about
2100 people the town of Fitz William is
a similar number it would be difficult
with all the other things that Selectmen
have to deal with and town meeting has
to deal with that we would ever get to
this but it's just as real a problem
there as it would be in the city of
Kean can I add to
that uh most if not well many if not
most of the U public charging stations
are on private
property and uh you need to have a
Statewide law that pertains to that
because municipalities just
would not have the authority to regulate
use of private property for this purpose
without the state law thank
you thank you Mr chair yep
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um you say that this is uh only
hurting rude people um but I'd like to
ask about line 10 of the bill um where
it says that uh the owner of the
non-electric vehicle that violates is is
punished um what if the owner of that
vehicle has no idea that their child or
vehicle well as the former father of
three
teenagers and owner of the vehicles that
they
drove I would say that there are a lot
of things that uh the owners of a
vehicle are responsible for whether I
was driving it or not so that's my
answer right that's the same as other
parking regulations right now that the
fine goes to the
owner uh this parallels exactly with the
enforcement mechanism of the handicap
parking spaces for example so the owner
is responsible for whoever is driving
the vehicle and you know a few mons to
go and charge his teenage son
the $100 he's up to that but it's the
owner that is responsible for the whole
whole list of parking and other
violations that uh occur when the when
there's nobody actually driving the
vehicle follow thank you
vehicle that happens all the time now
too so the rental companies if they get
a a ticket in the mail they they charge
thank you any other questions any other
questions from the committee
representative St Clair thank you how
how often uh when somebody parks in one
of these spots electric is it is it
running into a store or is it somebody
that's parking there for several hours
and yeah no
I a lot of
occasionally right now uh because the
market these things tend to be put out
in the Far
Corners you know they sort of relegate
these the EVS to the sort of less
desirable spaces of when Walmarts in
particular put them out at the edge um
and one of the disincentives for putting
in close to the store is that you know
the
people will will will park in them even
if they're not charging uh I did observe
a supermarket in this one just over the
Border in Maine where they did have the
EV charging spaces in a very convenient
location and they are
routinely parked in by people who say
you know this is the best space
available I'm taking it I don't
care further questions representative
sellers thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for the uh taking my question uh why the
$100 charges why not two three
four yeah I think that
uh I think we want to say that this is
less critical to the
to the needs of the public than
preventing handicap spaces from being
taken so I thought that it should be a
lower fine I think $100 is enough
to you know send a message but we don't
want to say that gez that you know this
is the same thing or as as serious an
issue as keeping a person with handicap
parking follow up actually it's another
question okay thank you Mr chair
uh these signs would be actually put on
private property uh so who who's paying
for the signs so it would be up to the
if it's on private property then they
they're they're providing the space of
providing the Chargers if they want to
be able to have people enforce this law
or want to enforce themselves they need
to put the sign up or have
a you know many of these charging
stations are logoed so they they they do
the same thing so yeah whoever builds
the would put the sign up pay for
it representative Hill thanks Mr
chair um are are people that part that
have EVS are people um Allowed by this
bill to park in that that spot even if
they're not
charging the answer is
no the only difference is that it may be
difficult to enforce if they're I mean
if they're parked in the space and
there's no cord plugged into them then
that's going to be pretty obvious and
you will do a photographic evidence of
that if they're sitting there and they
just you know the the charge was
completed at 11 o'clock and they're
still there at noon time it's going to
be kind of hard to prove that I don't
think that that's the biggest problem
because if you're once you're plugged in
they know you're there and they start
charging for idle time after a certain
period so the charging companies
themselves you know Tesla or whoever
have figured this out and they they they
add on idol fees to keep people
moving thank you yep representative St
Clair still have a question I do thank
you is it is it not possible for the
property owners private or even
municipalities to put up a sign that
says toezone for violators and then have
their vehicles tow well that is the
current solution one that I think many
property owners are reant to take and
you know I know the people that do this
deliberately as a political statement or
other statement you know basically wait
around and they see the tow truck show
up they just move the move the vehicle
and avoid it so it's not very effective
and you know
and it's bad public relations I think to
people
really I don't
know as a owner of retail space with
parking
lots you
really
are the last thing you want to do is
call the toe guy and have somebody's car
towed it just you can do it it's legal
at the C A Certain frustration level as
a property owner you do do that but I
can tell you in 35 years as a property
owner and manager I have had to do it
perhaps five times
and each time it they were egregious
offenders thank
you I I have a question I I see it's a
new
section uh are there any other parking
situations where the public actually can
participate with testimony and
photographs uh even with the handicap I
don't remember that being the
case so this this language about having
owners of drivers being able to report
is exactly the same language as we now
have for handicap spaces many of which
are on private space private private
parking lots so it's it's the same
mechanism I think that's the only one
where we have exactly that same
mechanism but this is
a deliberately attempt to be a parallel
process
um to that so it's you know that that's
been out there I think
I would guess that that's been very
effective in terms of providing a
disincentive for non non-handicapped
Vehicles any other questions from the
committee thank
you representative Gorski thank you Mr
chair and thank you both for taking my
question how often is this kind of thing
happening are you seeing it's like
happening once a day twice a day can you
give us a sense of in your research how
often is this
happening well my answer to that is it's
it's not a problem tell it's a problem
but when it's a problem it's a real
problem because if you're the guy who
just ran out of a charge and somebody is
parked in that space with their uh
diesel powered
F350 uh and they they're not coming back
anytime soon you're out of
luck so uh that's the that's the problem
it's just like how often was the problem
with handicap spaces a problem until we
started recognizing that as
a as a real thing that we need to deal
with I would say that
um you sort of looking at people's
reports people reporting on EV forums
and things like that it does happen with
some frequency perhaps given all the
number of spaces perhaps not you know
not all the time but it is a
um it's sort of a signal that uh
you know the states where I think it's
the worst of like Texas where they you
know are openly hostile to
Eves
um and in California where there are so
many EVS that they do you know that the
spaces fill up all the time and so when
it happens people you know post it said
this is an outrage and I think that it
it it contributes to the U overall image
of of this state in terms of its will
willingness
to um to provide for you know the
citizens who have
EVS uh and I and I know New Hampshire's
way behind I I understand we just lost
a an application for funding assistance
for uh environmental for Ev um charging
stations because lack of infrastructure
to to provide and enforce these things
so it's uh we got a long way to go this
is sort of one small step but all these
things kind of contribute to what how
people feel about their you know comfort
vehicles representative
ve thank you Mr chairman thank you
taking my question is this a you know
also somebody's business as well is this
similar to somebody take parking at a at
a gas pump and taking up the space at
the pump and you know the the retailer
who owns that pump is no longer get
getting Revenue because somebody's
blocking access I I would I I had
actually thought of using that analogy
thing right and um there are two models
one I mean there are several National
organizations on Tesla for one you know
charge point a few others who have their
own National networks mainly on the
interstates uh but most of these things
most of these public stations are owned
and
with you know where the owner keeps the
revenue and pays the you know electric
utility company and somebody else for
the software but that you know that's a
direct bottom line item for the for the
local
business yeah it if I install a Tesla
charging station at my facility in Troy
it is a $55,000 upfront franchise fee I
install the equipment I pay for the
electricity and I pay a royalty back to
Tesla
it's unfortunate we're here I'll ask one
last question um do you think the
hostility towards the electric vehicles
and the parking St parking spots might
have something to do with the federal
government forcing people to take part
in this absolutely thank you nobody's
required to buy one
is are required to to offer them that's
right seeing no other questions thank
um next up Michael Fitzpatrick
representing the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services not
taking a position on the bill according
to this looking for three
minutes
welcome morning Mr chair members of the
committee Mike Fitzgerald I'm the
assistant director of the uh air
Resources Division at the Department of
Environmental Services and my testimony
on this bill and the following bill will
be be very similar as was noted we are
not taking a position this bill in
particular is not a major environmental
issue um however we do uh our
agency um administers the Volkswagen
trust uh fund and uh diesel emission
reduction act funds both of which allow
for um some use of those funds to to be
used for um uh electric vehicle
infrastructure and uh we also conven
a group of state agencies who have
interest in um providing electric
vehicle infrastructure and promoting EVS
for environmental and other reasons um
and uh again we're not taking a
particular position on but um we do
certainly think this is a valid concept
of of uh you know these spaces are
allocated for charging and as was noted
very similar to uh gasoline vehicles but
um I would also note that there are two
uh bills this session
there there are a number of bills
relative to electric vehicles in a
number of committees and there are two
bills this session one in the house and
one in the Senate that would create
commissions to uh study issues relative
to electric vehicles I don't know you
know both of those seem to be moving
forward I obviously I assume only one
ultimately will um uh be be passed but
um we we think that um certainly uh
bills that are related to electric
vehicles um it might be worth seeing uh
these commissions come through and and
allow them to study these issues and
make recommendations um again this one
seems you know certainly uh positive but
uh the following Bill we we would have
the F the same similar testimony that um
that these study commissions might be
vehicles for better understanding these
issues uh so with that I will uh I'll
stop and I may expand upon it a little
bit in the following bill but um I'd be
happy to take any questions or wait till
afterwards thank you sir any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much I have nobody else signed up to
speak on House Bill 1416 so I'll close
the public
hearing uh give us just a couple of
minutes to reset and we'll be taking up
next
okay
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on host Bill 1332 FN relative to
prohibiting electric vehicles from
parking and parking
garages and I did it again chair
recognizes the prime sponsor for
back good morning again chairman and the
rest of the committee today I I'm
bringing a bill to prohibit electric
cars parking and parking garages and no
I'm not one of those people that he just
talked about that are making a statement
against electric vehicles if you want to
own one knock your socks off right but
I'm here on the safety aspect right I've
been a firefighter for over 40 years and
that's Public Safety is what I do and
and look out for
so couple of concerns the first one a
regular F-150 pickup truck weighs
approximately 4,500 lb let's give or
take the lightning electric pickup truck
same size as the F-150 weighs over 7,000
pounds
right so a lot of these electric cars
counterparts the some of these garages
were not designed to hold that way they
look at an average car they and I'm sure
the state's engineer here over here we
can attest to that and maybe I'm wrong
on that but I know that New York City
has had one garage already collaps due
to electric
cars over stressing the
garage the other piece of that is that
carf fires burn at least twice as hot
close to 2,800 degrees when they're
burning and they reach that fairly
quickly you're now going to start
weakening the the concrete and the metal
underneath
it so it used to and now you're looking
at a vehicle on the side of the road as
opposed to an electric vehicle burning
in a garage when it's burning on the
side of the road what used to take us
one fire Tru and maybe a th
gallons maybe now is taking us the first
alarm assignment two engines a ladder a
couple of tankers a lot of tankers
because we used to take us a th000
gallons now it takes us 30 to 40,000
gallons because we have to cool this
vehicle off until it stops burning and
hopefully it stays stops burning but it
tends to reignite as soon as it starts
warming back up so we've seen an average
of people of the fire department dealing
with these for at least three
hours now you put that in a garage next
to other vehicles that are probably
going to light off as well and if it's
another electric vehicle on either side
of it we really have an issue and and
it's going to
be a major incident on a on a car fire
the other piece of that is that when
these burn they give off deadly gases
hydrogen volatile organic uh compounds
CO2
methane and I know you don't think it's
kind of an enclosed space but it is
right even though there's some air
getting in and out of there or if you go
down into a basement garage there is
none so now you have all these highly
toxic gases in a garage space that
people are trying to get out of and may
not make it it's not just regular smoke
right
um so that's
what the reason for me bringing this
forward and I'm not the only one um that
believes in this that these will become
an issue if they are put in a garage and
now if you add charging stations in that
garage because we know
that manufacturers recommend that you
trickle charge them which is like an
overnight charge then there's a standard
charge that charges it in a few hours
and then the rapid charge that charges
it in less than an hour
that the
manufacturer doesn't recommend only in
emergency cases should it be used
because it degrades the battery and sets
it up to
fail
so and usually they fail while they're
charging so this is why I bring this and
if there's any questions I will try and
answer them for
you thank you very
much where do we start representative St
Clair I saw him
first thank you Mr chair do do we have
any uh information history of fires like
this in the state that have happened in
garages not in our state
because electric cars are kind of slow
to catch on here but they are starting
to thank you represent
rumo thank you Mr chair thank you um my
first qu I have a couple of questions if
I
uh my first question to be clear this
bill is not about charging stations in
garages correct correct so discussion
about whether they're charging in the
garage would be dangerous or not sort of
secondary right to the question of
whether they're allowed in the garage
okay um in terms of the chemical
compounds or the toxic compounds that
might be released in case of a fire
could you tell us a little more about
the difference between a EV fire in a
garage in terms of what's released you
started some references but compared to
a no organic volatile compounds there
may be some
Co
um and depending on what's burning in
the car but these batteries that's
what's killing a lot of the people in
these
cars uh when an EV car goes into thermal
runaway the Electric System shuts
down and the doors are
electric you have to find the manual
override in your car it's usually a some
kind of cable that you have to pull to
release the door most people don't even
know that they exist so we're finding
all of these people in the back of the
cars trying to get away from this from
these
gases some people call it smoke but in
that smoke is all these gases that are
killing them before normal smoke would
but a park and garage fan is not going
to change did you have a followup yes
may I please have a followup but a
parking garage man is not going to
resolve that safety risk or change that
for somebody in a car fire it's just one
more thing that gets added if the
vehicle is in a parking garage those
hazardous gases are there and where you
could probably walk through regular
smoke you won't walk through these okay
one more may I have one more please
being way too kind but go ahead one
more at the beginning you referenced the
F-150 being a certain weight and that
the EVS we talking are much heavier
correct correct okay so is it is the
weight the concern here in the rest of
so the weight is one of the major
concerns so should we be looking at a
weight limit for parking garages versus
an EV limit or prohibition if you're
concerned about the risk how are you
going to do that say that once we hit
this certain weight 10 EV come in and
take the weight
of 20 parking spaces that they can't
charge for I think I'm trying to
understand we're going back and forth
okay thank you we know how this works
representative Fox thank you Mr chairman
so just so I understand um New Hampshire
has had no
instances in a parking garage that I
parking garage at this point and
unfortunately in in the fire reporting
system there's no check box for electric
car that I've seen yet so it comes in as
a carire MH could be electric could not
be follow up Mr chair yep follow up
thank you is there any data Nationwide
how many we're talking about so New York
City has had them and New York City has
had well that's where they all are right
well New York right New York City's not
not New Hampshire but but that's where
the EVS are parking in parking garages
at the moment and and if I had something
else I'd be happy to offer it do you but
I know they've had one garage collapse
already due to
EVS thank you yeah if you anything you
can find for the committee in terms of
statistics would be greatly appreciated
I will see what I can do representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I know we
currently have
uh regulations or or stipulations on on
the location of um gasoline filling
stations um there my understanding is
you can't have them near a assisted
living facility and a movie theater and
a something like that are you are you
heading
to similar types of ordinances some
other states have already started with
them near near the same operations that
that you can't have them in front of
certain buildings um because if if they
let
go so goes the building right and you
don't want something that's G to um tend
to burn quicker so I know just like they
limit gasoline stations they're going to
start limiting areas that you can have
them follow up yep follow up thank you
would would it be advisable to do that
under the under um individual
municipality ordinances again almost uh
running to representative Jones's
question earlier is that something that
should be mandated by the state or is
that something that should
be town and city
ordinances I'd like to see it as a state
ordinance right so we're all on the
thing playing field because you're going
to drive into one town you can park
there and you go to the next town and
you're expecting to park in the parking
garage and no that town says no right
and that's kind of why we do a lot of
things Statewide to keep everything the
same so you don't have to have like a a
little chart saying well in Manchester I
can Nashville I can't conad maybe right
we know yes we can or no we can thank
you see
representative
C thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question um was concerned
about the definition of parking garage
is this just for municipal garages or is
it privately owned like at a shopping
mall or possibly like some condos uh
have uh essentially a
snowshed that people park in that might
be caused and called a garage even
though it doesn't have doors on it
that's a really good
question uh I would like to see it for
all right because Fire doesn't care
whether it's private municipal or the
condo association but I I get that first
floor with a little cover over it to me
that's not really a parking garage I'm
talking about a structure that they're
elevated or below ground enclosed
somewhat right granted you know I know
the outside ones have some air flowing
through but not a whole lot and now it's
around representative Jones and we are
falling behind
folks thank you Mr chairman I'll make
this quick
um just following the concept that
you're going with um the some of the
international Freight Carriers there's
been issues in the past couple years the
ones that transport over uh Vehicles
overseas they've had fires because of
the battery and battery operated
vehicles and theyve some of those
carriers will no longer take any
electric vehicles I doesn't this go
along with the same concept that you
were presenting I would say so I I
believe I watched a big
Toyota carrier ship burn up pretty well
and I I was led to believe that that was
an electric car that started
that
all right seeing no other questions
thank you very much thank you next up
chair recognizes representative fauler
who is opposed to the bill looking for
three
minutes want to say that I think this is
a a bill looking for a problem and then
coming up with a solution that's not
actually very helpful so I'm just going
to put a few facts out there I own a
electric
car uh my battery weighs 9 00 lb about
900 lb
additional uh the whole car is under
3500 so the difference between a pickup
truck and a regular car is a lot greater
than the difference between
a my car with the gas engine and my car
with
battery
uh the
basic well I'm going to say that battery
fires are pretty rare
250,000 bolts have been built 18 battery
fires 18 battery fires that were caused
by a manufacturing defect which has
since been corrected and was uh due to a
recall supervised by the national
Transportation safety
board
that um Tesla data is that they have had
car fires now car fires were all uh
sources uh batteries which are rare a
car getting caught in a house fire car
being involved in a collision in the
highway all sources one Tesla fire for
every 205 million vehicle miles traveled
you take the rest of the fleet the
gasoline powered Fleet it's one vehicle
fire for every 19
million uh vehicle miles travel
so
regular vehicle fires from all causes
all sources and all types 10 times more
fires T reports of all these battery of
all these uh battery cost fires no
confirmed deaths due to the battery fire
340 some pod people died from gasoline
vehicle fires last year
largely in collisions but but somewhere
elsewhere so the problem with fires is
not electric
vehicles uh electric vehicles are in
fact a big improvement over the current
Fleet uh I just want to point out that
when cars first started carrying
gasoline we had to switch from water
only fire suppression to you know foam
on most of these uh vehicles uh same
thing here that we need to find the
right method I understand the current
method of choice is to have a a
fireproof blanket that you just throw
over the vehicle and let it burn you
know if the battery is burned then the
cars total which is actually true of uh
gasoline powered vehicles as well so a
lot of
misinformation a lot of fear
monitering uh you know if there's a fire
uh the fire departments need the tools
to fight these fires then we should
provide them but Banning the vehicles
isn't going to help
um EV sales are
growing um worldwide maybe not New
Hampshire we kind a
little slice here that's not typical but
you know in Norway for example 90% of
new cars sold electric vehicles
throughout Europe typically 30 35% China
35% California 20% I mean there are
going to be a growing number of electric
vehicles out there they're going to be
everywhere uh
let's attack this Pro problem rationally
and not with fearmongering thank you
thank you seeing no questions thank you
very
much J recognizes Mike fitgerald from
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental
Services no position on the bill looking
well morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee again uh for the record
Michael Fitzgerald assistant director of
the air Resources Division at the
Department of Environmental Services uh
as noted we take no position uh in
particular but uh as I noted on the last
bill uh there are two study commissions
that uh L legislation uh to create two
study commissions uh currently one in
the Senate and one in the house to uh
look at barriers to electric vehicle uh
introduction into into the marketplace
and another one to look at safety issues
um and I would note that there are
several bills related to EVS uh in this
session um last week in the public works
committee two bills were considered one
that was relative to forced Labor uh
used in components for electric
vehicles um and another one that would
ban the state from procuring electric
vehicles uh both of those bills were
found uh one one was uh found itl and
one was was uh recommended for entum
study um we again we convene a a
Consortium of uh State agencies that
have interest in uh uh EVS from uh
several aspects and uh we do fund EV
charging um and so our uh thought at
this time would be that the committee
consider um uh holding this potentially
holding this forum study uh while these
other um study commissions do their work
uh relative to some of the information
uh that was requested Ed earlier um the
State Fire Marshal on Senate Bill 430
did testify that to the best of his
knowledge the information that he could
gather that New Hampshire has
experienced two battery fires two
electric vehicle battery fires um so far
we've have approximately I believe our
data shows and from this from
DMV um data that we we looked at um that
we have approximately 12,000 EVS in the
state now that number is certainly
increasing relative to weight um the
weight issue is really not an electric
vehicle issue cars are getting heavier
overall um it's between 1980 and 2020
the average weight of uh the average
vehicle increased about 1,000 pounds and
also uh the number of much larger
vehicles that are being purchased today
you large EV um uh SUVs and pickup
trucks Etc so this is not the weight is
not really an electric vehicle issue um
granted some of them do way more but uh
um vehicle Les are just getting bigger
heavier and and uh uh increasing in
weight overall so um parking garages
certainly have to accommodate that as I
say just o in that uh 40-year period I
noted an increase of 1,000 pounds per
vehicle um and that was well before EV
penetration into the market so again we
think these are issues that need to be
studied um and uh collect real data not
just anecdotal information and um we
would certainly ask the the committee
think about um um looking at uh interim
study while these other commissions can
do their work assuming that they move
ahead so with that I'd be uh happy to
take any
questions thank you sir I'm going to
start off with one can you supply the
committee with any data uh referring to
internal combustion engine Vehicles
becoming heavier as as opposed to going
the other direction because with Cafe
standards and mileage requirements I
thought lightweight was the goal for the
last couple of decades so can you give
me some info yeah yeah well I'll the
reference that I I just u i I'll I'll
pass that information on to the
committee yes thank you sir questions
from the
committee seeing then thank you very
much uh last up chair recognizes
representative Hobson uh represent are
representing Rockingham 14 in support of
the
sorry thank you very much honorable
colleagues um thank you for hearing my
testimony today my name is Deb Hobson
and I'm a rep state representative for
district 14 out of Rockingham
County uh I come today to support uh as
a co-sponsor
1332 I was privileged to attend a
training seminar for SE Coast Fire
Chiefs there were 4 to 500 other first
responders in the late summer last year
I was surprised to hear some of the
concerns brought to light from this
training and how I think they pertain to
this measure uh the electric vehicle
fire temperature starts at
2800 and the fire size doubles every 15
seconds uh in parking garages it would
spread to other cars very quickly the
fires get so hot they melt tires and
asphalt and there's no way to remove
these cars from the parking garages
a conven well unfortunately uh rep P had
my statistic uh Ford F-150 weighs 4500
lb the same electric model weighs about
7,000
um the smoke from an EV fire is not
smoke it's toxic gas consisting of
hydrogen voc's CO2 and methane which is
toxic to vehicle operators and First
Responders there is currently no
firefighting protocol to fight these
fires except to let them burn themselves
out when deprived of oxygen as some
suggest submerging in water or bur
burying them in the ground they reignite
when oxygen hits them as long as a month
later the temperatures are so hot that
First Responders can't get near the fire
their gear is rated for just
800 thermal Run Runaway is a chain of
events that typically starts with the
gradual breakdown of EV battery cells
causing the preheating of the EV battery
cells and the pack the elevated
temperature within the EV battery cells
causes the organic solvents to break
down resulting in the release of gas
increased pressure and temperature
Beyond its flash point uh fires and EV
batteries are triggered by uh thermal
runaway events um which is a safety
hazard in lithium ion batteries and can
be caused by short circuiting mechanical
stress to the EV battery from an impact
during an accident overheating or poor
cooling techniques condensation and
moisture as we see in Florida with some
of the uh tropical storms um or a
manufacturing defect most protocols now
indicate to let the fire burn itself out
or to D douse with large amounts of
water anywhere from 5,000 to 25,000
gallons of
water requiring more manpower hours
which leaves these fire stations underst
staffed while supervised in these
problems need to be worked out before
they can become mainstream uh please
vote out to pass on this measure um I
also wanted to uh agree with Mark P that
I am not anti- EV I just think that we
need to work these problems out so thank
you for hearing my
testimony thank you very much any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you again uh with nobody else
signed up to speak on House Bill 1332
I'm going to close the public
hearing uh just a couple of minutes to
regroup we'll be going into 1445 and
much to my surprise I have 1 2 3 four
five six seven 8 nine 10 people um
signed up to speak uh I don't normally
do this but we will today we are going
to be doing time limits of three minutes
which is what most of the people are
requesting for time so give us a moment
okay welcome back I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 1445
which is relative to bicycles electric
scooters and electric unicycles and as I
mentioned as I close the previous
hearing I am going to with all these
cards go for the three minutes per
speaker which is being requested by the
overwhelming majority so fair enough um
I will also ask at this time I have
eight of them or nine of them that are
all opposed uh if you do hear the points
that you wanted to bring up uh it's
certainly acceptable and okay to wave
off speaking if you choose to uh in
other words the committee doesn't need
to hear the same issues over and over
and over so that being said the chair
recognizes the prim sponsor
representative trer good
morning good morning Mr chair and
members of the transportation committee
I'm representative Douglas Traer belnap
8 representing the towns of Belmont
Tilton and SED today I come before you
with House Bill
1445 since I put this bill in I have
learned some information about
ebikes um I'm coming before you to
request this bill
um move forward for the safety of the
public that's my goal my goal was not to
repeal um some of the current laws I'm
looking to add I have learned that some
of these class one 23
ebikes have some
regulations I've learned that there are
some new classes out there that that are
unclassified are more of the problems
that the ones that are doing over um 28
miles an hour and the way they're being
operated on roadways and also doing some
further research and speaking to some of
the professionals that will probably
testify here today also includes
electric scooters and the electric
unicycles I know recently one of the um
unicycles was clocked by a law
enforcement officer in the state at 83
miles an hour on radar on a public way
that is very
dangerous um my concern with the way
they're being operated is recklessly and
um they're not enforcable by law
enforcement the way they're written um
and another concern there are some
courts in this state that are taking
people's driver's licenses for their
poor Behavior which could include
driving well impair reckless driving and
telling them to purchase an ebike and
they haveit still will continue on an
electric bike or classified electric
bike I understand a lot of people use
electric bikes they class one two and
three you know for exercise the rail
Trails where they're allowed and um
certain places like that my goal is not
to take that away from them but I do
have a problem with some of these
electrical bikes the way they're being
operated you know on sidewalks around
people cutting and out of vehicles and
there's no enforc
um
capability question I have and I I've
been asking if I can get an electric
bike or something they classify as an
electric bike that does 45 miles an hour
or faster can I write that down
Interstate
93 because they're not classified as
bicycles I mean there are some and
depends who you talk to they say they
are but what I'm being told they're
not um so my goal here is maybe to do an
amendment change some of this and
present it to the
committee um clarifying some of this or
also I know this house will I believe
it's 14 or 1543 that I believe you're
executing later
today maybe we can do a interm study
between the two bills and come up with
something feasible for the safety of the
public and not to interfere with the law
Biden uses of the electric bikes but
again there are
unclassified bicycles that are
electric um that are not assisted by um
human um Power so basically they have a
throttle kind of like a motorcycle and
I'm not trying to classify these as
motorcycles they are a form of a
bicycle however some of the speeds are
um unreasonable in the way they're being
uh operated so that's why I'm before you
now is thinking of the safety of the
public also if some of these uh
electrical
bicycles will use unclassified gets in a
motor vehicle accident and does bodily
harm to somebody do they technically
have to report it to the B motive
vehicle the way it's written right now I
am being told
no um so these are concerns to me so um
that's why I'm hoping that you'll
um let me do an amendment bring that
forward addressing more of the detailed
concerns after I were um have listen to
some of the uh people that deal with
these more than I do um to see if we can
come up with a better solution if not
would ask for an infm study between this
bill and I believe it's
1543 thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee I guess we've gotten the
message we know what we know what the
goal is seeing then thank you very much
thank you for your time consideration
have a good
recognizes does that say Joan Joan
Joan Joan D what's
bill
okay um I'm Joan Diario I'm from New
Market New Hampshire my husband and I
have had ebikes for at least three years
we ride on rail Trails we ride in bike
Lanes um I
think the representative who just spoke
before is correct in that what really
needs to happen is you need to
look at electric vehicles in the
whole Spectrum there declare them as
bicycles or electric vehicles that are
not Cars they're not motor
vehicles um and there should be you know
granted some way of uh you know
enforcing traffic laws when when we ride
we ride in the street we
have uh headlights and tail lights we
wear helmets we use mirrors we
signal people who don't do that should
be pulled over you know I have no
problem with that but I do the way that
1445 is written they don't want people
to be on rail trails and bike paths what
the heck are we supposed to do most most
of the people who ride ebikes are older
or they have problems riding a regular
bike uh because of health issues and at
least when they're riding a bike they
have a chance to get out in the air or
enjoy nature without you know my husband
has COPD if he didn't have an ebike he
couldn't
ride um and I will let other people
speak up on on what they want to do but
I I'm not in favor of this business as
written thank you very
up our chair recognizes Tim Blackman
representing con conquered Lake sun
railro rail trail oppose to the Bill
chair there you
go um so uh I'm also opposed to the bill
um section one is completely unnecessary
and
counterproductive um existing law 265
144a paragraph 7A already allows a city
town or state agency having jurisdiction
over a bicycle or multi-use path to
prohibit the operation of a class one or
two electric bicycle on that path um so
the proposed uh prohibition of category
1 and two ebikes is unnecessary it's
already covered um the the legislation
is drafted um also came up with a new
arbitrary speed of 15 miles an hour
which is not supported by industry um or
laws written elsewhere around the state
so category one and two ebikes um will
either assist you or help you get to up
to 20 miles an hour so introducing an
arbitrary 15
mph um speed limit is unfor forcible and
impractical because that's just not
what's being built in the world today
um prohibiting category one and two
ebikes on multi-use trails and rail
Trails is counterproductive to what
we're trying to do which is to get more
people out on trails and
um moving um under their own power um to
to improve their health and to um help
reduce carbon emissions so I'm I'm not
going to take up any more of your time
um thank you written testimony has been
handed over thank you very
much uh and I apologize next up did you
have questions any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and I I
apologize next up chair recognizes
representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members for the record my name
is alen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
that's new market and new Fields when I
first saw this bill I kind of wondered
what in the world problem could this
possibly be what could be existing that
this needs to to fix um so I have been
this may seem weird I've been contacted
by more constituents about this opposing
this bill than any other bill that we've
had before the general court this year
um so there is a three class uh
classification system that 38 States
including New Hampshire have already
adopted we've already dealt with this
this is
unnecessary um and this would treat
ebikes like motorcycles because as I've
testified before you all before I am a
motorcycle Enthusiast and like
motorcycles ebikes when you're a rider
on two wheels you are taking on all of
the risk when there is an impact with a
motorcycle or especially with an ebike
the car wins so to penalize people
riding ebikes it is nonsensical
um not only as you've already heard are
people who ride ebikes people who have
physical limitations who wouldn't be
able to ride a regular bike they may be
elderly or may have other issues and
they're trying to do the right thing
they're trying to get out outside get
some exercise um and this bill would
penalize those people but also this bill
penalizes other people who are trying to
do the right thing and that is people
who cannot drive and need an ebike to
commute or to do other things they
either cannot drive or cannot afford a
car so we say that we expect people to
you know work their way up and do the
right thing and do what it takes to get
to work and save money and all of those
things but then this bill would penalize
that so New Market my town has both
types of these ebike Riders which is why
I've heard so much about this
bill um and so I I still am stuck with
what in the world problem could be
existing in that this is going to fix
that it's worth penalizing those two
groups of people and with that I'm happy
to take questions or just
leave thank you very much any questions
again uh next up we shall recognize
Sylvia leet representing herself opposed
bill welcome uh thank you for allowing
me to speak uh I'll make it very brief
because I think it's been covered quite
well that the class one two and three
ebikes are already regulated enough um
and I just want to show you my really
Doge eared rail trail book I think I've
taken advantage of every single rail
trail in New Hampshire on my class one
ebike and when I I was appalled when I
read read this proposed uh legislation
and I hope that you will find it
inexpedient to legislate and finally I
will say though that house bill
1543 that talks about personal electric
vehicles the
pevs um they are totally different than
ebikes
and this bill that you have here today
um should be inexpedient to legislate
thank
questions next up Richard Anderson
representing himself also opposed to the
bill
welcome thank you very much for having
me my wife might me write this all down
because I get carried away and I'm going
here I speak really fast as a school
teacher for 33 years so I can do this I
think I seldom come to con to speak
about pending acts but acts that I have
spoken in the
past I've
read proposed to achieve something I
have read reread this act and haven't
found any purpose in this act at all
safety does not seem to be a reason as
section one there's a reference to ebike
that exceeds 15
miles 15 miles an hour but that that
does not reference the dangerous road
bikes racing Along on rail Trails even
faster than that section 1A States a
need bike is not to be operated on a
bike path or rail trail so why did we
invest all this money in bike paths
section three notes that manufacturers
supp put labels on bikes after January
1st 2020 what if there isn't a label or
it's not in 6po font if they're applied
what does one do ER it's been removed or
painted over to make the bike look cool
will a DMV local town office or an lbs
be responsible for relabeling the frame
section four sounds good on the surface
but again who's going to be responsible
for these labels section six describes
class one bike this is an ebike is known
as a pedal assy bike where a motor cuts
out at 20 M hour when my wife and I
bought our ebikes we didn't consider
this class bike as it's way safer to
cross streets and roads using a throttle
rather than trying to start quickly
pedaling across this is just another
point of how this act is unrealistic
about safety section 7 has a whole list
of safety features that would be
required why aren't these required on
lightweight fast road bikes these bikes
are ridden on both roads and bike trails
Road Riders on their skinny Tire
lightweight bikes wearing black spandex
that makes them blend into the road and
surroundings aren't required to show any
of these lights but present a real
Hazard to drivers section nine makes no
sense at all talking about a person
riding the back of a class 3 bike the
most popular passenger cargo bike in the
world is a rad wagon that carry three
children and it's a class two bike I
really don't think a fall at 25 M an
hour off the back of a class 3 bike is
going to do that much worse than a crash
at 18 mil an hour on a Class 2 bike or
20 m per hour on a Class one bike that
would be for a rider or
passenger section 10 brings home that
this is not designed to make biking
safer as it talks about ebikes ebikes
that don't go over 15 M an hour I don't
think exist but if they do they need
lights whereas lightweight road bikes
that go over 20 M an hour on bike trails
and Roads don't need any lights I think
there's something wrong with this
picture so here we are with no purpose
for this act in three years of riding
rail trails in state and out of state we
have never experienced any ebikes
passing Folks at excessive speeds or
riding in an unsafe manner EXC when my
wife and I ride we have always the
announce our
presence excuse me sir I have to be fair
to everybody you've gone over the three
if you can wrap it up please the pardon
if you can wrap it up I have to be fair
I said three for everybody I'm
sorry
uh to wrap it up safety is not the
consideration of the bills that leav
spandex tour to force want to be folks
riding trails way past over 20 mil an
hour it possibly is the purpose of not
bringing any uh tourist of the state um
I guess Troopers would be at the border
registering these bikes other states are
spending millions of dollars on their
bike trails so we can go and enjoy
riding our ebikes there so I don't know
New Hampshire is a regression I guess
not in the
future if anybody would like a copy of
this yeah if you do have copies if you
want to distribute them that'd be great
thank you very much thank you have a
great day you
too uh next up chair recognizes Edward
Kelly representing the ebike store in
bill uh thank you I'll be brief uh I
have uh just to be up front here I have
two ebike stores uh in uh in New
Hampshire I have hundreds of clients
with ebikes all over the state and I
have uh many people from out of state
come to my store to rent the bikes ride
on the rail Trails everybody gets this
quick guide to Safe cycling which goes
over all the safety regulations
uh pertaining to the safe operation of
bicycles in general but particularly
ebikes uh we always emphasize that you
obey all traffic laws like any other
vehicle riding on the road with cars
trucks uh motorcycles anything uh we
don't ride on sidewalks preferably we
ride in uh bike lanes and on rail Trails
so again I would just like to uh
reiterate what the previous uh speakers
have said about uh about the bill uh I'd
be happy to take any questions you might
have otherwise I'm done thank you any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you again
thanks ah next up sh recognizes David
toam representing the Hampshire rail
Trails Coalition who is in opposition to
the
welcome morning Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Dave top him
from Salem and for a quick flashback and
intro I'm also the president of the New
Hampshire rail Trails Coalition you'll
be hearing before long from Paul vad
who's with the bike walk Alliance I'm
talking about the legislation in front
of us now
1445 in a quick flashback I was highly
involved with the current legislation
that make class 123 three bikes legal
here in the state back in 2019 I was
working primarily with uh Earl Sweeney
Department of Safety he was very
instrumental and we formulated that to
come up with the plan that's in place
today as mentioned before we have 38
states around the country with this mod
legislation we do not see any reason to
change what's in place with the
guidelines we have for that today you
folks would have had received this
particular handout back on January 9th
when I testified in favor of
1543 so moving ahead I'll just say
that I also full disclosure yesterday
morning I had a very pleasant chat for
an hour and 10 minutes over Zoom with uh
representative Doug tro we agree on
intent that we want to keep the public
safe we don't want these outer class
Vehicles I'm not talking class one two
three they're covered I'm talking these
devices that can go 40 50 miles an hour
with the push of a button that's showing
up more and more places and there are
more of these vehicles showing up now
throughout the country than the total
sales of electric cars and trucks if you
haven't seen them in New Hampshire you
will soon so bottom line again I can a
chat with a representative TR yesterday
we feel the current bill 1445 needs some
work I would definitely entertain us
working together to come up with things
that work and what don't work
collectively along with the 1540 three
that go going to exec this
afternoon but hand in hand we say safety
safety safety and safety of the public
there's nothing safe and you get people
who don't know what they're doing they
get on vehicles that they can't control
and whether you want to call these outer
class Vehicles motor motor vehicles are
not that's up for the legislature to
determined I say anything that has the
power and speed of Motor Vehicles that
we have to register today with licenses
registrations everything in place you
have the same exact scheme we have
something I think we need to control
that's all I have take any questions
thank you sir any questions from thank
you for your time seeing none thank you
again uh next up J recognizes Paula Bard
representing bike walk Alliance of New
Hampshire opposed to the bill with
written testimony fantastic welcome yep
thanks for being here my name is Paula
Bard um I represent the bike walk
Alliance of New Hampshire your Statewide
biking and walking advocacy organization
um I also serve on the New Hampshire
Traffic Safety commission as the voice
for bicyclists and pedestrians in our
traffic system uh and as you may know
people do use bicycles for both
Transportation Recreation and exercise
um and some people use bicycle as a
primary means of transportation either
by choice or by necessity we do opposed
1445 as written for the following
reasons um this bill currently
improperly uh restricts the rights of
class one class 2 class three uh it
lumps all classes of electric uh bikes
together which is not appropriate
there's really uh you know this outof
class or higher powerered set of
electric uh bicycle like vehicles that
really need to be regulated differently
and separately uh without restricting uh
or changing the existing state
regulations on class one class two and
class three bicycles which we the bike
walk Alliance of New Hampshire and New
Hampshire rail Trails Coalition helped
put in place back in
2019 um ebikes are uh you know
regulation on ebikes is currently
available in signage U many
municipalities have gone to Great
Lengths to update signage and policy
based on the current guidelines allowing
class one and class two on rail Trails
by default um this you know 1445 as
written would affect bicycle rental
businesses um with due to the verbage
that's really not quite right in that
bill um I want you to know that you know
I myself 62 years old I consider my
fitness level mediocre or average I I
recently purchased a class one pedal
assist uh electric bike I purchased it
specifically so I could ride on rail
Trails its pedal assist technology has
no throttle I have to be providing
pressure uh providing energy to make
that bike go uh I don't think I've ever
gotten that bike over 20 M an hour I
just don't have it in me even with the
pedal assist so um my particular bike
has a maximum wattage of 320 Watts Which
is less than 1/ half of horsepower
that's a very small amount of power uh
in this class one bike and the category
of electric vehicles that we really do
want to regulate we're talking about
vehicles that have much higher wattage
and power ratings literally uh in into
the thousands 1,000 watts of power 5,000
watts of power and some of these things
that look like electric bikes with 5,000
watts of power are currently being
marketed as if they are ebikes and there
some people are out there telling people
that oh this is an ebike you can ride it
on a rail trail that is really not true
if it's something that has that level of
wattage or power it is definitely does
not meet the classification of a class
one or class to ebike um and in closing
we do support the notion of a work
session uh or study session to look at
the overlap and contradiction between
the two bills 1445 and
1543 let me know if you have any
questions thank you very much any
questions seeing then thank you again uh
next up chair recognizes castline DeMent
from the Department of Motor Vehicles
for information only yeah good morning
chairman repres Representatives um I
just want to say that we've worked with
representative Traer for the last couple
times for this bill and whatever you
have for questions we're here to answer
if you want to register them we're happy
to register them um if you want to do a
study committee we'll work closely with
you to get you
information thank you very much thank
you any
questions any questions seeing none I
thank you I kind of knew and final card
thank you for everybody um Bard the
Hampshire Department of
Transportation uh also not taking a
position on the bill
welcome good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Jerry Bard
I'm the active Transportation engineer
for the Department of
Transportation Act of Transportation
deals with um self-propelled means of of
Transportation most people biking and
walking typically so I'm here to speak
on the house bill 1445 specifically how
it relates to Electric
bicycles one of the goals of the
recently released uh New Hampshire
pedestrian and bicycle plan is to
encourage active
Transportation The increased use of uh
ebikes has a significant potential for
making bicycling easier and increasing
the number of grand stators who uh
commute and get around by bike uh as
currently Written House Bill 1445 adds
restrictions Beyond those in existing
New Hampshire laws which has already
been
stated um and these laws are common in
many other
states um so this bill could potentially
discourage uh ebike use this opinion is
based on House Bill 1445 propos proposal
to repeal New Hampshire's current ebike
law and create two uh classes of ebikes
one uh group of ebikes that are capable
of motor
assist of speeds less than 15 miles an
hour and ebikes capable of motor assist
speeds 15 miles an hour or faster the
New Hampshire do is unaware of any
ebikes that limit the motor assist to
less than 15 M an hour therefore all
ebikes in existence today would based on
this bill be restricted from all bike
paths and rail
trails and some equipment required by
this bill for example brake lights uh is
is not currently available on most
existing
ebikes and if there are any questions
I'll take any questions thank you very
much uh representative St Clair thank
you Mr chair um are there do you have
any numbers of how many of these exist
in the Hampshire you know that are being
used
ebikes the class one class two class
three I I don't have the number on on
the class one class two class three e
bikes no how about higher up the out
ofcl class bikes that that this bill and
House Bill 1543 tried to address I I
don't know the numbers of those
either yeah yeah thank you yep uh any
other questions I have one uh I sat on a
commission a few years ago the road
usage of non-traditional motor vehicles
and the discussion of ebikes came up as
well as the scooters and all the U um
the other electric devices that are out
there we were told at the time that the
federal government was in the process of
coming up with their own definitions do
you know if that's true or if they're
having
progress and I asked that only because
that was our reason for not really
getting into it uh and spending a lot of
time with our own definitions to find
out that the federal government has a
different
idea um I believe and I'm going to leave
it if some other experts might be able
to answer this better uh there there is
a federal code that that identifies um
class one class two ebikes up to 20
miles an hour but that's the that's the
only Federal Regulation I'm aware of
okay I didn't know if You' heard I'll
look into it as well um so uh any other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very much uh that is the last
person I have signed up to speak I'll
close the public hearing on host Bill
1445 um that is the end of our hearings
today we do have executive session at 2
o'clock uh I know we get into lunch a
little bit but if the Republicans can
shoot to be back here for 1:00 that
what
okay welcome back
everybody first of all I'd like to thank
our substitutes for the
day
um hopefully we can try to get through
this quickly as usual we're pretty
organized uh we do our first four bills
in order are early bu so we're going to
act on those no matter what uh I'll
start off by saying if you are here for
House Bill
1158 relative to establishing an
exception to Vis vessel registration or
House Bill
118 relative to the issuance of driver's
licenses for aliens temporarily residing
in New Hampshire uh there are pending
amendments for those which I do not have
yet so we're not taking those up today
so if you're here to see the outcome of
those uh I'll reschedule those for next
week that being said I believe we can go
in order I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
1044 relative to the non-mandatory
issuance of certificates of title for
certain vehicles and the chair
recognizes representative foot for a
motion thank you Mr chair I would like
to itl uh H bille 1044 okay motions itl
is there a
second second by representative Hill
would you care to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair uh back in January
9th we heard a on House Bill 1032 and uh
we ultimately passed that in committee
by a vote of 17 to Z ultimately making
this bill
unnecessary fair enough anybody else
from the
committee uh I did get an email from the
prime sponsor who has said basically um
it's not ready for prime time in her own
words so she's recommending an itl from
us um that should take up any discussion
on this if there is no more I'll ask the
clerk to call the RO when he's ready I
have the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to
legislate okay Vice chairman votes
yes representative Smith yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill
yes representative Reid yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative St Clair yes
representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative Vu yes representative
rung yes representative Jones yes
representative
Kerry yes representative
clemon
Pond
yes 19 to
zero can I have a vote oh I'm
sorry
still representative chairman
Walsh uh let me let me think let me
think about this for a
second
yes that's it I think that's it now it's
19 to zero okay our recommendation of
itls adopted 190 without objection
consent it'll
go okay consent it is I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
1044 a couple of minutes to reset we'll
I'll open up the executive session on
House Bill
FN equalizing the fines for operating at
ohrv with a driver's license suspended
and operating a snowmobile with a
driver's license
suspended
floor
wow representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman I would
recommend uh for OTP motion is ought to
pass is there a
second seconded by representative St
Clair would you care to speak to your
motion
sir thank you Mr
chairman uh this seems like a very
simple uh bill it um we did get
statements from uh the New Hampshire off
highway vehicle association uh who
supported the bill because it equalizes
the lines for operating and and it was
also understood that fishing game
desires to correct the disparity so I
think it's one
that our staff
committee the reader digest of what or
version of what this bill
does right now if you look at the
penalties are driving without a license
while no HRV and on a snowmobile they
match but they are less than the penalty
for driving without a license if you
were in a motor vehicle and so what this
does in a nutshell is it makes the
penalties go from their current ones to
matching the penalties of if you are
driving a motor vehicle in the same
circumstances from 250 first offense and
500 second offense so and it moves it up
from $186 I think u in the in the
current language so it's not a huge leap
it just equalizes ohvs snowmobiles and
committee interestingly enough okay
representative Hill with that being said
I will be voting no on this um I haven't
heard any reason to
increase um the penalties or fines on um
driving without a license for so I'm not
in favor of increasing them simply to
equal fair enough I don't recall any
other reason other than that
myself representative syes so we did
hear testimony from the prime sponsor
and I've also been participating in uh
ohrv commission um
and
uh there is there's a there are problems
up north particularly um and especially
at big events uh in terms of being able
to uh enforce uh the
speeding this particularly speeding
issues um but more more so even
suspended driver's licens people
operating so I think this is an attempt
uh on the part of uh the people of the
North Country to um equalize the playing
field anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role when he's ready the motion
on
11:38 is ought to
pass okay Vice chairman Gorski votes
yes representative Smith yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill no representative Reed yes
representative foot
sers
no representative
Sykes yes representative Rich
yes representative St Clair yes
representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative Vu yes representative
rung yes representative Jones yes
representative carry yes
representative padan yes good job than
chairman Walsh
no
16-3 okay our our recommendation is
adopted ought to pass 163 this will go
regular calendar so I will close the
executive session on House Bill 1138
pl's Amendment
same one same
time
okay
I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1304 FN local relative to vessel
registration and boat fee decals chair
recognizes representative sers for a
motion thank you Mr chair I motion not
to pass motions ought to pass is there a
second seconded by representative St
Clair
um before we go into the discussion this
this is open for further Amendment chair
recognizes representative sellers once
again thank you Mr chair I'd like to uh
motion to accept the amendment 2024 d00
69h it's an amendment to the 1304 f b
local okay representative sers moves
Amendment 0069 H is there second
seconded by represent St CLA care to
speak to your motion represent yeah in
the uh in the um the amendment excuse me
it it's just adding where basically
which say display of numbers it's adding
and decals all right so we're adding
that in because uh the boat fees uh is a
decal sticker we had to separate uh so
we could get the uh Federal money to
continue because we weren't in compliant
at that point so this brings it back
into
compliance that's it and this was I know
representative sers was on the committee
that studied this uh and this amendment
came in from the prime sponsor as a a
late discovered error uh anybody else on
the
amendment seeing on all those in favor
adopting the amendment say I I oppose
nay okay so the amendment's adopted um
motion on the floor is ought to pass as
amended care to speak anything to at
representative sellers were you good no
that's good I I think overall we're just
trying to come back into compliance
that's all very good fair enough anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rule motions ought to pass as
amended okay Vice chair Gorski votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Pratt yes representative Hill yes
representative Reed yes representative
foot yes repres representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative stclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Vu yes
representative rung yes representative
Jones yes representative kry yes
representative flon yes rep and chairman
Walsh yes
Zer our recommendation about the passes
amendment is adopted 190 what's up
consent I did hear consent without
objection consent it'll
be okay um so consent it'll be I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
1304 and in order we will go to 1543 in
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1543 FN relative
to personal electric vehicles chair
motion thank you Mr chairman I I move
itl on 1543
atent uh motion is inexpedient the
legisl is there
second seconded by representative Hill
sir uh there's a a couple of bills on
this and there's a lot of confusion
about what should actually be done and I
don't think this these either of these
bills are really ready so um it' be
better to take the time and look into
them deeper get a better bill out of
it fair enough anybody else from the
committee and I will agree uh we've got
two bills that deal with pevs this year
they kind of do different things
everybody agrees some change needs to
occur but nobody can agree on either one
of these directions so let's try again
next year uh we could have interim
studied it but again same result I will
and somebody gave me the idea I'll
mention to the New Hampshire
Transportation Council if this is a
topic they want to tackle on their own
so for that I'll I'll support the it
motion myself anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the RO when he's ready motion is
in expedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Pratt yes representative Hill yes
representative Reed yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative St Clair yes
representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative Vu yes representative run
yes representative Jones yes yes
representative carry yes representative
Clemington
yes and chairman Walsh
yes 19 to zero okay a recommendation of
an expedience to legislates adopted 190
without objection consent it'll be and
seeing then I'll close the executive
session couple of moments and we'll go
into
for I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1062 relative to the use of Special
cover plates she recognizes
representative C for a motion I move
ought to pass motions ought to pass is
second seconded by representative Hill
would you care to speak to motion thank
you uh this clarifies something that
some people believe was already
acceptable and that is to allow the use
of just one of the Special cover plates
over one of the regular plates on your
car okay here anything enough simple
enough anybody else from the
committee and it the bill really is that
simple I thought you could I thought you
else so um my concern is that if we I
think we need clarity about whether you
can already do it and if you can already
do it then we don't need the bill and so
I I think we don't have quite enough
information and you know for that reason
I may I will probably vote against the
motion fair enough but I think this bill
actually is the clarification it adds
one sentence to the statute anybody else
from the committee I know this is going
to be a huge floor fight either
[Laughter]
way uh with nobody else I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll when he say the
motion is ought to
pass okay Vice chairman Gorski votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Pratt yes representative Hill yes
representative Reed yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes Representative
syes no representative Rich yes
representative St clear no
representative
Fox no representative Rambo no
representative veu
no representative rung no representative
Jones no representative Kerry no
representative Clemington no and
yes 10
n sweat that one
outp 109 109 okay I knew we were going
yeah our recommendation about the pass
is adopted 10 to nine regular calendar
it'll be um if you'd wish to speak to
this on the floor please give me your
name as soon as possible I'll close the
executive session on El
distress
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 1083 relative to Vehicles
held in joint teny with RS of
survivorship chair recognized as
representative Hill for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I would move out
to pass on house Bill 1183 I'm sorry
1083 yep uh motion is ought to pass is
second was that represent fox fox or
Romo I didn't see okay um een
representative
fox h would you care to speak to your
motion certainly um so my plain reading
of section 261 colon 17 uh Roman 3 says
that you can do this uh that the
surviving owner who when it is uh joint
ownership held be with an and between
their names um the surviving owner can
transfer the vehicle without obtaining a
new
title up to and including the the day
that uh a new registration is needed so
it would seem to me logical if you can
transfer it at that point with just the
single signature and a death certificate
that there shouldn't be any reason why
uh a new title is required and in a
situation that I had um this
Veteran's spouse
said virtually every piece of her life
is being um separated from her husband
as she goes along and this was just the
last piece that um they told her she
couldn't have beyond that year I Grant
you that's a heartstring thing but I
will also point out that in any number
of other circumstances as a financial
advisor I run into joint and
survivorship all the time with um with
financial instruments and they don't
require you to retitle things um they're
held perfectly fine um even though it's
a higher worth than probably this
vehicle is definitely more than this
vehicle is so um I just don't see any
any reason why um it should be required
here um and not uh over just that time
period so with that I'm voting a to
committee all right seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call the role when he's
ready the motion on the floor is ought
to
pass okay Vice chairman G votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Pratt yes representative Hill yes
representative Reed yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich
representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Vu yes
represent representative rung yes
representative Jones yes representative
kry yes representative pingon
yes chairman
Walsh
yes 19
Z yep our uh recommendation about the
pass is adopted 190 I heard a motion for
consent without objection consent it is
I'll close the executive
I'll open up the executive session on
House Bill
1122 FN relative to lights on Motor
Vehicles chair recognizes representative
Gorski for a motion thank you Mr chair I
I motion to OTP HB
1122 um I'll speak to it seeing as how I
am the prime sponsor on it it's a simple
bill this was a housekeeping oh sorry I
get ahead of myself as there a second
representative Jones thank you uh so
I'll speak just briefly to it this was a
housekeeping measure right basically for
the Department of Motor Vehicles it just
clarifies the use and color of some of
the headlights that are becoming popular
on uh Vehicles nowadays it also deals
with your ride share companies and the
the lighting that they use which I don't
know if you've seen Uber but when
they're on they're blue and they do look
like law enforcement so this simply
requires them to shut it off when
they're driving and turn it on when
they're parked simple enough um there
there some a few changes in in in in the
penalties too but they reminder that
wasn't the reason for the bill was just
to clarify some of these other things
anybody else from the
committee seeing none the motion is
ought to passel ask the clerk to call
the role when he's
ready okay Vice chairman Gorski votes
yes representative
Smith yes yes representative Pratt yes
representative Hill yes repres
representative Reed yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative veu yes
representative rang yes representative
Jones yes representative Kerry yes
representative Clemington
yes chairman Walsh
zero okay our recommendation about the
passes adopted 190 I did hear consent
without objection consent that is I'll
close the executive
session uh few minutes next up will be
three
yeah
you
for
okay um change of plans uh I've decided
only because of the
circumstances uh to give the prime
sponsor who could not make it that day
one more opport opportunity um and I
guess it was an attempt to send me some
written testimony which I did not
receive so we're not in the rush on it
it's not an early bill in all fairness
let me find out what's going on with
this so I'll hold off on 11:23 we will
take up
11:27 and we are ready so I'll open up
the executive session on House Bill
1127 relative to the revocation and
suspension of driver's licenses and the
chair recognizes representative foot
thank you Mr chair I move to OTP House
Bill
1127 motion is ought to pass is there a
second seconded by representative sers
would you care to speak your motion
sir uh thank you so basically this is a
two-part Bill uh number one is it was at
the request of the DMV since they're now
in the live state to state and they made
the internal changes um back in 2022 to
eliminate the need to surrender an
actual driver's license license and
those individuals can then use that I
that license as a valid ID the second
part of it of the aspect is it adds upon
way and that's essentially
it the lawn mower Bill anybody else from
the
yeah um yeah no it's a simple bill it
makes sense to me anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll last the
clerk to call the world when he's ready
the motion is ought to pass okay Vice
chairman Gorski votes yes representative
Smith yes representative Pratt yes
representative Hill yes representative
Reed yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich
representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes oh was sorry that was in
Stereo that was good the enthusiasm is
it's awesome it's
the representative V yes representative
run yes representative Jones yes
representative Kerry yes representative
Clemington
Z okay our recommendation about the
passes adopted 190 I did hear a motion
for consent without objection consent
that is I'll close the executive
session um as I said hold on
representative
syes um as I think most of us have
talked I'm going to hold off on 1158 and
1118 but we did have our second peev
bill of the
day and so I think we're all in
agreement
to so we are going to do the executive
session on 1445 today as well um the
ranking member and I have agreed to take
it up and it'll help us move along so
minute
okay I'm going to open up the executive
1445 hold on here I thought it was
prepared relative to electric bicycles
electric scooter scooters and electric
un
motion thank you Mr chairman I move uh
she I recognizes representative oh
thought you thank you um I move uh itl
on hb1
1445 thank you sir motions inexpedient
to legislate seconded by representative
Hill you care to speak to
it yeah it was the same same discussion
we had on U the other uh P bill just
it's not ready with too much confusion
over what each bill does and what should
be done so hold up on
it fair enough I agree uh these can
still be worked on in the future same
thing I'll talk to the N Transportation
Council anybody else from the committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the rule the motion is inexpedient to
legisl you see okay Vice chairman Gorski
votes yes representative Smith yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Reed yes
representative foot yes representative
C yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Vu yes
representative rung yes representative
Jones yes representative Kerry yes
representative Clemington
yes chairman Walsh yes
19 to zero our recommendation is
adopted of itl in expedient to legislate
190 any objection to consent seeing none
I'll close the executive session okay
before everybody scrambles I do need my
reports before you leave please there's
a major push to get these and actually
it helps me too so I'm not looking for
them for
days um also thank you very much we're
in pretty good shape even with taking
the 23rd off for the primary we only
have nine bills left to hear um so my
goal is to get this done in the next two
Tuesdays uh I'll break it up I'm
probably going to hear everything next
Tuesday that we have left all nine of
them if we have time for exec uh we will
if not the following week will be an
executive session mop up so if there's
no questions or are no questions thank
you very much and I'll see you next
anybody yeah I changed my mind uh we
have the one bill from representative
Lynn um I truly want to do something
with
that does anybody interested in I can
form a subcommittee is anybody
interested to tackle that I have a draft
Amendment from excuse me excuse me
you no anybody interested in the
subcommittee on House Bill uh where am
session on representative Linds Bill
1158 do we want to put a committee
together on
that 1158 which is relative to the
establishment of an exception to vessel
registration the lemonade stand for
boats
Bill we don't I'm asking I'd like to see
it fixed I get a an amendment from
Captain dun Levy I don't think it goes
far enough I know representative Hill
has looked into a different statue
trying to fix it with Hawkers and
peders I guess I'm just looking for some
help uh if we if we all truly want to
fix this if we can get two two or three
people together and uh try to hammer the
out that would be greatly
right okay help this out a little more
complicated
fantastic so I will I will okay I've got
the names fantastic thank you very
much anything else for the good of the
you